saleh après tant que nouveau le cas
natif bien via les notifs notre tour
d'horizon des jantes et du monde sportif
le toujours patron la ligue nationale de
hockey s'est retrouvé les deux pieds
dans l'eau après que le soleil d'après
midi au fin fond de la glace de la
patinoire installée sur les magnifiques
berges du lac taureau le soleil
or fait fondre la glace une interaction
peu commune que les experts des arénas
réfrigérée redouté selon le commissaire
de la lnh gary bettman a déclaré après
l'annoncé du report en soirée dimanche
contre les golden aide et l'avalanche et
les rayons soleil avait toujours été son
ennemi sunshine or l'ennemi
hormis un vampire est ce qu'on a déjà vu
qu'un batman de fait des recherches sur
internet il ya aucune photo de cailloux
bettman à l'extérieur
pour moi c'est clair ce rendez vous ne
direz pas cet homme ne vous rappelle pas
indifférente regarder ça à la table de
négoce de l'accord
c'est clair qu'ils vous disent certains
qui dort dans sa communauté on a beau
être en février c'est sûr que ça allait
pas bien se passer un mac à midi d'or au
nevada mais comme paysage pour le retour
des nordiques
c'est quand même plus beau que le sang
des autres tous les joueurs sont arrivés
avec des lunettes soleil
c'est sûr que la glace à neuf ans après
le deuxième des deux matchs disputés
finalement soirée david pasternak était
vraiment fâché de devoir sortir du
vestiaire des brumes ce parce qu'il est
en train de rater ce qui visiblement sa
chanson préférée barbie girl d'aqua
harry caine commandant de compagnie
comme une barbie let's go paris
qu'est-ce-qui joueurs sont beaucoup dans
le vestiaire
sidney crosby a joué son 1000e match
dans la ligue nationale de hockey et ses
coéquipiers lui ont rendu hommage
la meilleure façon en attachant leurs
patins comme leur capitaine tellement ça
ce n'est crosby pas scandale jamais un
mot déplacé
professionnelle jusqu'au bout des la
ceni crosby c'est la super star la plus
ennuyante de l'histoire de la ligue
nationale et 6% combler sa et ses pubs
de tim hortons a aussi on le trouvait la
façon de s'assurer que les jeunes
espoirs soient fin prêts pour le hockey
professionnel
on les entraîne maintenant dès l'âge de
8 ans à se battre en équipement complet
je sais qu'il faut experte en pour
survivre en russie j'espère qu'ils
viendront patrick schoenahl tv etc est
témoin et aux roumains
on aimerait prendre un moment pour
demander à tous les partisans du
canadien de bien vouloir prendre moment
de répit et de partager en fait la
native à tous les gens que google
ça va vous aider à mieux respirer et
nous après avoir gagné son quatrième
titre du grand chelem
naomi osaka a tenu en premier a remercié
son adversaire en finale que l'effort
brédy et par bienveillance avant de le
faire elle lui a demandé comment elle
préférait quand la belle jeune et fort
hood génie ferry en a un autre qui vit
cros-de-cagnes incarner fin
ok on a combattu en effet en effet dans
sa mise aux voix que jenny ce traité
pour peur c'est la chose la plus baveuse
que j'ai vu cette année normes et aux
accords s'est excusé mais bien
franchement le mal était fait d'autres
faire quoi frédéric von anhalt
c'est pour nous à la semaine prochaine
si vous avez aimé
laissez nous un commentaire et partager
la vidéo car si vous n'avez pas aimez
vous pouvez mettre un petit bonhomme
fâché de ces corps est aussi la donne et
indirects c'est bon pour nous les gros
bras comme barbie au gol et chose que je
fais pour ce show là